Now, this is the interesting question. What about AI? Well, in theory, I've just said that you can now do anything you want? Yeah, but do people do that? But it turns out they don't. They tend to follow the path that's already been set. And it turns out that AI does this as well. It actually reinforces it. Because all the training data is based on stuff that's already out there. So guess what? It's really good at the stuff that's already out there. Listen, folks, it's hot garbage, you know, whatever their ranking is, like, Fortran and Cobol are like the two fastest growing languages. We're still needed. Our insight is still needed. The robots aren't going to replace us just yet. And the fundamentals still matter. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 265, recorded on. December 11th, 2025. My name is Connor, and today I interview both Kevlin Henney and Damien with Kevlin and I chat about the past, present, and future of programming languages. And Damien is the technical director of the Yao conferences, and this is his first year in this position, and he gives us his review of Yao 2025.
现在，这是一个有趣的问题。人工智能呢？理论上，我刚才说你现在可以做任何你想做的事，对吧？但人们真的会那样做吗？事实证明他们不会。他们倾向于遵循已经设定的路径。事实证明，人工智能也是如此。它实际上强化了这一点。因为所有的训练数据都基于现有的东西。所以你猜怎么着？它非常擅长处理那些已经存在的东西。听着，伙计们，这简直是垃圾，不管它们的排名如何，比如，Fortran 和 Cobol 是增长最快的两种语言。我们仍然被需要。我们的洞察力仍然被需要。机器人暂时还不会取代我们。基础知识仍然很重要。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 265 期，录制于 2025 年 12 月 11 日。我是 Connor，今天我采访了 Kevlin Henney 和 Damien，我和 Kevlin 聊了编程语言的过去、现在和未来。Damien 是 Yao 大会的技术总监，这是他担任该职位的头一年，他为我们带来了对 Yao 2025 的回顾。
All right, I mean, we've got 20 minutes. We might not record for the whole time. Maybe we'll cut this into the first part, and maybe we'll talk. to Damien later, but we haven't talked yet about your Yao talk. I mean, technically it was your Yao talk, your NDC Oslo talk, and then I saw it on YouTube at one point, so you probably gave it at ACU or some other conference, and fantastic talk as well. It changes, so depending on the version you see online, I mean, we'll probably link the ACCU one, maybe the NDC one, that one is, I don't, not sure if the recordings are out for that yet, they might be. And changes every time. And even right before we started recording this, I was like, I got to get set up for a sec. And
好的，我的意思是，我们有 20 分钟时间。我们可能不会全程录音。也许我们会把这段剪辑成第一部分，也许我们稍后再和 Damien 谈，但我们还没谈过你的 Yao 演讲。我的意思是，从技术上讲，那是你的 Yao 演讲，你的 NDC Oslo 演讲，然后我在 YouTube 上看到过一次，所以你可能在 ACU 或其他会议上也讲过，那也是一场精彩的演讲。它会变，所以取决于你在网上看到的版本，我的意思是，我们可能会链接 ACCU 的那个，也许还有 NDC 的那个，我不确定那场演讲的录音是否已经发布了，可能已经发布了。而且每次都在变。甚至在我们开始录音之前，我就说，我得先准备一下。然后
you were editing some slides and you're injecting photos all the time. So tell us a bit about that talk. And then maybe you can tell us about predictions. Because we didn't get to talk about that. The last time we interviewed you, one of the questions I had, and admittedly this was like a year plus ago now, it was kind of like, what is your, you know, you've given tons of talks in the past that cover different languages and paradigms. And, you know, how does the age of AI and LLM's impact, you know, in your opinion, programming languages and, you know, the languages that we're learning even if we're not typing in them. Anyway, so you can cover your talk and then future predictions. Okay, so the first thing is that, you know, the future impossible to predict it is,
你一直在编辑幻灯片，一直在插入照片。所以给我们讲讲那个演讲吧。然后也许你可以告诉我们关于预测的事情。因为我们上次采访你时没来得及谈这个。我当时有一个问题，诚然那是一年多以前的事了，大概是，你的，你知道，你过去做过很多涵盖不同语言和范式的演讲。那么，在你看来，人工智能和大型语言模型时代如何影响编程语言，以及我们正在学习的语言，即使我们没有在用它们输入代码。总之，你可以讲讲你的演讲，然后是未来的预测。好的，首先，你知道，未来是无法预测的，它是
so I'm going to borrow from Yoda there. So obviously there's certain things that can be wrong here. The title of the talk is one of the most prosaic and literal that I've ever done. It is called the past, present and future programming languages. I couldn't come up. with anything snap here but i thought you know here's something it it does it does what it says on the tin so there's a couple of aspects of that i look at the um i guess there's three three general parts to it one is i look at a number of different language rankings and without you know and i don't push i don't lean on the numbers too hard i'm just saying here is here's a language here's language rankings and they are they are made from different criteria so you know um
所以我打算借用尤达大师的话。显然，这里有些事情可能会出错。演讲的标题是我做过的最平淡、最直白的标题之一。它叫“编程语言的过去、现在和未来”。我想不出什么更吸引人的标题了，但我心想，你知道，这东西它名副其实。所以这有几个方面，我看了，嗯，我想大概有三个部分：一是看了一些不同的语言排名，而且，你知道，我不会太依赖这些数字，我只是说，这是某种语言，这是语言排名，它们是根据不同的标准制定的，所以你知道，嗯
So, Tyobi, which is Conner's least favorite. But what's interesting about that is it is susceptible to web search and SEO. So that gives us kind of like an indicator of its potential volatility, but also its biases. I look at Red Monk, which is based on GitHub and Stack Overflow. Stack Overflow is not looking so healthy these days as a source of useful long-term data. And I also look at I-Triplea spectrum. And the point here is that I've looked at others. they each have their areas of focus and I don't push too hard on the numbers what I'm actually interested in
比如 TIOBE，这是 Connor 最不喜欢的。但有趣的是，它容易受到网络搜索和 SEO 的影响。所以这给了我们一种关于其潜在波动性的指标，但也反映了它的偏见。我看了 Red Monk，它是基于 GitHub 和 Stack Overflow 的。Stack Overflow 作为有用的长期数据来源，这些天看起来不太健康。我还看了 IEEE Spectrum。重点是我也看了其他的。它们各有侧重，我不会太纠结于数字，我真正感兴趣的是
and one of the reasons by the way folks why the talk does actually update is that I will always try and include the latest version in that and I did have to do the version I have just done in Sydney uses different rankings to the ones I did earlier in the week and last week because you know you know when when a rank new ranking is updated I will incorporate it so the point there is to look initially at the top 10, the top 5, and say, well, have they moved much? And then look at the top 20. It's like, are they moving much? And are they, and then this is the interesting, first of all, they're not moving much. There is movement. It's not static, but it is gentle. The movement within them is gentle. The stuff in the top 10 is surprisingly stable. There is movement up and down. It's not, again, it's not static. But the really interesting bit comes when you look at the age of the languages and I divide them
顺便说一句，伙计们，演讲之所以会更新，是因为我总是会尝试在其中包含最新版本。我确实必须这样做，我在悉尼做的那个版本使用的排名与我本周早些时候和上周做的不同，因为你知道，当新的排名更新时，我会将其纳入。所以重点是首先看前 10 名、前 5 名，看看它们变动大吗？然后看前 20 名。它们变动大吗？然后，这是最有趣的部分，首先，它们变动不大。确实有变动。它不是静态的，但很温和。它们内部的变动很温和。前 10 名的东西出奇地稳定。确实有起伏。它不是，再说一次，它不是静态的。但真正有趣的部分在于当你观察这些语言的年龄时，我把它们
initially I sort of say okay here's the languages from the 20th century and here are the languages from the 21st century we are a quarter of the way through the 21st century and 21st century languages are only just making a dent in the top 20
最初我大概是说，好吧，这是 20 世纪的语言，这是 21 世纪的语言。我们已经走过了 21 世纪的四分之一，而 21 世纪的语言才刚刚在前 20 名中崭露头角
by any ranking okay and it is it's just like well that's kind of interesting and that did not use to be the case I then break down the languages and I say, okay, well, let's look at their overall age. And the fun bit is not just to look, you know, 1950s, 1960s, 1970s and whatever,
无论按什么排名，好吧，这确实很有趣，以前可不是这样。然后我细分了这些语言，我说，好吧，让我们看看它们的整体年龄。有趣的部分不仅仅是看，你知道，1950 年代、1960 年代、1970 年代等等，
when was the language created? Look at it in terms of social generations. And the fun one is that there is a huge millennial bump. Most, the language space in terms of the mainstream of what people are using is dominated by languages that will be considered millennials. It's kind of an interesting sort of oblique observation, but the key thing here is that the languages are biased towards the old. So if you think about, so we've got Python, let's think about Java,
语言是什么时候创造的？从社会世代的角度来看。有趣的是，有一个巨大的“千禧一代”高峰。大多数，就人们使用的主流语言空间而言，被认为是千禧一代的语言所主导。这是一种有趣的斜向观察，但这里的关键是，这些语言偏向于老旧。所以如果你想想，我们有 Python，想想 Java，
we've got C++, we've got, these are all languages that are quite old. See, yep, that's still there in anybody's top 10. And then we've got JavaScript, well, that's mid-90s. We've got a few clearly coming in, TypeScript is making, you know, that is relatively modern. And then I hear people talking about Rust and Go, and they're saying, yeah, but these are new languages. these are young languages. They're not.
我们有 C++，我们有，这些都是相当古老的语言。C 语言，是的，它仍然在任何人的前 10 名中。然后我们有 JavaScript，嗯，那是 90 年代中期的。我们有一些显然正在进入的语言，TypeScript 正在取得，你知道，那是相对现代的。然后我听到人们谈论 Rust 和 Go，他们说，是的，但这些是新语言。这些是年轻语言。它们不是。
You know, Go is 2009, it was introduced, okay? Rust is over 10 years old at this point. These are making some kind of dent, but the couple of things to be aware of is, first of all, when we look at any language ranking, as a human's we have a bias
你知道，Go 是 2009 年推出的，对吧？Rust 到现在已经超过 10 年了。它们确实产生了一些影响，但有几件事需要注意，首先，当我们看任何语言排名时，作为人类，我们有一种偏见
towards any form of ranking. We think it's linear. We think of them in linear terms, but they're not. Number one is normally way more adopted than whatever number two is, and so on. By the time you hear, 10, it's just that it's a skewed curve. Not necessarily a power law, but some of them do look like that, but it's highly skewed. So it turns out that anybody's top five or top 10, whatever
倾向于任何形式的排名。我们认为它是线性的。我们以线性的方式思考它们，但事实并非如此。第一名的采用率通常远高于第二名，依此类推。当你听到第 10 名时，它只是一个倾斜的曲线。不一定是幂律，但其中一些看起来确实像那样，但它是高度倾斜的。所以事实证明，任何人的前 5 名或前 10 名，无论
ranking is highly biased towards that and has a very long tail. And that's really interesting because there is a lot of activity happening in the long tail. The tail is getting longer. There's lots of new languages to be create and new language is easier these days than it used to be. You can actually just make up a spec, shove it at an LLM and say, hey, you know, generate me something. or pretend you are the interpreter for this. But what's happening is that the core is consolidating. And there's a number of reasons for that. And it is interesting to look at the rate of change.
排名如何，都高度偏向于此，并且有一个非常长的尾部。这真的很有趣，因为长尾部分有很多活动。尾部正在变长。现在创造新语言比过去容易多了。你实际上可以编一个规范，扔给一个大语言模型，说，嘿，你知道，给我生成一些东西，或者假装你是这个的解释器。但正在发生的是核心正在整合。这有很多原因。观察变化率是很有趣的。
So if we go back to the 90s, Java was introduced mid-90s. Within five years, it was dominant. It was in the top 10 languages. That's not the case now. Well, why? 30 years ago, if you were around in the business, 30 years ago, you might have thought the world had a lot of code. Compared to what it has now, merely a fraction.
所以如果我们回到 90 年代，Java 是 90 年代中期推出的。五年内，它就占据了主导地位。它进入了前 10 大语言。现在情况并非如此。为什么？30 年前，如果你在这一行，30 年前，你可能认为世界已经有很多代码了。与现在相比，仅仅是九牛一毛。
most of the code that exists is the stuff people are getting jobs in. In other words, it is to extend existing systems. It is to maintain existing systems. It is to work in organizations where that is the default culture. And so these languages have a foothold. They have the foothold of the incumbent. It's just that that's where the jobs are. That's where the training is.
现存的大部分代码是人们赖以谋生的东西。换句话说，它是为了扩展现有系统。它是为了维护现有系统。它是为了在以这种方式为默认文化的组织中工作。所以这些语言有立足点。它们有现任者的立足点。只是因为工作机会就在那里。培训就在那里。
That's where the companies are. This is not to say that you're not going to get movement elsewhere, but the movement is being slowed down just by the sheer presence of all the other stuff. So there's a deceleration. Now this is the interesting question. What about AI? Well, in theory, I've just said that you can now do anything you want. Yeah, but do people do that? But it turns out they don't. They tend to follow the path that's already been set. And it turns out that AI does this as well. It actually reinforces it because all the training data is based on stuff that's already out there. So guess what? It's really good at the stuff
公司就在那里。这并不是说你在其他地方不会有变动，但变动被所有其他东西的存在所减缓了。所以存在减速。现在，这是一个有趣的问题。人工智能呢？理论上，我刚才说你现在可以做任何你想做的事。是的，但人们真的会那样做吗？但事实证明他们不会。他们倾向于遵循已经设定的路径。事实证明，人工智能也是如此。它实际上强化了这一点，因为所有的训练数据都基于现有的东西。所以你猜怎么着？它非常擅长处理那些
that's already out there. And this is an observation, Anders Halesberg, inventor, you know, designer of TypeScript and C-sharp and Teva-Pascal, he made this observation as well. It's just like there's all of this data out there. The amount of Python code out there, the amount of blogs about Python, the amount of training material is just staggering.
已经存在的东西。这是一个观察结果，Anders Hejlsberg，TypeScript、C# 和 Turbo Pascal 的发明者，他也做出了这个观察。就是有所有这些数据存在。Python 代码的数量，关于 Python 的博客数量，培训材料的数量简直令人震惊。
So automatically you have a bias in an already biased landscape. It reinforces that. It just puts, you know, touches the scales a bit, puts the thumb on the scales even more. But what is interesting is the more recent trend that I've noticed is the way that LLMs are using languages. So, you know, how many R's are there in strawberry? If you haven't come across this one, this is quite a fun one. A couple of years ago, if you asked ChachyPT, how many hours are in strawberry, it would tell you two.
所以你自动在一个已经有偏见的景观中拥有了偏见。它强化了这一点。它只是，你知道，稍微触动了天平，让天平更加倾斜。但有趣的是，我注意到的最近的趋势是大型语言模型使用语言的方式。所以，你知道，草莓（strawberry）里有多少个 R？如果你还没遇到过这个，这很有趣。几年前，如果你问 ChatGPT，草莓里有多少个 R，它会告诉你两个。
You know, typically the LLMs, because they don't think about words the way that we think about. They don't have that, they don't have that kind of relationship to the letter, the visualization and all the rest of it. It feels really odd. I can see that there are three R's on the screen. How come you can't? Well, that's not how LLMs work. But what is interesting is that their answers are getting better. And they're not getting better just because people are putting if statements in around.
你知道，通常大型语言模型，因为它们思考单词的方式与我们不同。它们没有那种关系，它们对字母、可视化等等没有那种关系。这感觉真的很奇怪。我能看到屏幕上有三个 R。你怎么会看不到？好吧，大型语言模型不是那样工作的。但有趣的是，它们的答案正在变得更好。而且它们变得更好不仅仅是因为人们在周围加了 if 语句。
Oh, we're going to ask the strawberry question. They're getting better because the way that LLMs are being couched and surrounded by other software is like, wait a minute, this is a problem that is already solved. How is it solved? It's solved by programming. And what is interesting is a, I guess about six months ago, I asked the R, I asked the R's in strawberry question to chat GPT and Gemini, and they both gave me the right answer. And I asked each of them, how are you doing this? And they both said, yeah, we wrote Python code. So, you know, show me the code. And they showed me the code that did literally count the number of ours. Here is the word, and here is how you write the code. What is funny is that the latest Gem and I, so I checked this out a couple of weeks ago when I was updating the slides, I don't even have to ask. it. When I ask, when I don't even have to ask it, how did you do this? When I ask it, how many hours are in strawberry? It actually has a tag saying show code. In other words, the whole point
哦，我们要问草莓问题了。它们变得更好是因为大型语言模型被其他软件包裹和包围的方式，就像，等一下，这是一个已经解决的问题。它是怎么解决的？它是通过编程解决的。有趣的是，我想大约六个月前，我问了 ChatGPT 和 Gemini 草莓里 R 的问题，它们都给了我正确的答案。我问它们每个人，你是怎么做到的？它们都说，是的，我们写了 Python 代码。所以，你知道，给我看看代码。它们展示了确实计算了 R 的数量的代码。这是单词，这是你如何编写代码。有趣的是，最新的 Gemini，所以我几周前更新幻灯片时检查了一下，我甚至不需要问它。当我问它，当我甚至不需要问它，你是怎么做到的？当我问它，草莓里有多少个 R？它实际上有一个显示代码的标签。换句话说，重点是
is LLMs are now consumers of programming languages. They look at something and go, yeah, I could kind of like wave my hands at this problem and do it, you know, LLMly, if that's an adverb. You know, I could take advantage of this kind of like pattern matching ability or I could recognize that using my pattern matching ability, this is a really classic programming thing. I shall write some code and that I think is interesting. So LLMs are becoming consumers of our languages and by default it chose Python. So there's a reinforcement again that we are seeing. There's all of these things that are effectively decelerating what's happening in the mainstream of languages, which is not to say that there isn't interesting stuff happening. I just want to say that's out
大型语言模型现在是编程语言的消费者。它们看着某样东西，然后说，是的，我可以对这个问题挥挥手，用大语言模型的方式解决它，如果这是一个副词的话。你知道，我可以利用这种模式匹配能力，或者我可以认识到，利用我的模式匹配能力，这是一个非常经典的编程问题。我应该写一些代码，我认为这很有趣。所以大型语言模型正在成为我们语言的消费者，默认情况下它选择了 Python。所以我们再次看到了强化。所有这些东西实际上都在减缓语言主流中正在发生的事情，这并不是说没有有趣的事情发生。我只是想说那是在
in the long tail. Whether it breaks through to the mainstream, well, the road has got a lot steeper. That's kind the issue. And that's part of the thesis of the talk. I also have a bit of fun in the middle of the talk talking about where how old some of the features we think of actually are and how they are rolling into still rolling into languages. So maybe you got excited about the fact that your language is adopted or now allows you to do multiple assignment. A comma B equals C comma D. That's a 1963 idea right there. And there were languages in the 70s and it's slowly been coming into languages. Maybe your language has a yield keyword or equivalent to allow you to do kind of routine or iterator like stuff, yeah, that's a mid-1970s idea. The thing is that these
长尾部分。它是否会突破到主流，嗯，道路已经变得陡峭多了。这就是问题所在。这也是演讲论点的一部分。我在演讲中间也开了一些玩笑，谈到我们认为的一些功能实际上有多老，以及它们是如何进入，仍然在进入语言中。所以也许你对你的语言被采用或者现在允许你进行多重赋值感到兴奋。A 逗号 B 等于 C 逗号 D。那是一个 1963 年的想法。70 年代就有这样的语言，它正在慢慢进入各种语言。也许你的语言有一个 yield 关键字或等效功能，允许你做类似协程或迭代器的东西，是的，那是 1970 年代中期的想法。问题是这些
innovations of the 60s and 70s are still working their way into languages now, and there's not a lot of novelty in the mainstream space. And that's kind of reinforcing itself. I think what we're going to see is that in the next decade or two is that languages adopt these features, so Python in 10 years is probably going to have a whole raft more features. C++ is going to, well, C++. Every three years, there's something radically different about C++. It's going to have a whole load of more stuff, but it's still called C++. So the languages are changing in place, but the set of languages is changing ever more slowly. Yeah, what to add and what to ask.
60 年代和 70 年代的创新现在仍然在进入各种语言，主流空间里没有太多新奇的东西。这在某种程度上是在自我强化。我认为我们将在未来十年或二十年看到的是，语言采用了这些功能，所以 10 年后的 Python 可能拥有更多功能。C++ 将会，嗯，C++。每三年，C++ 就会有截然不同的东西。它将拥有更多东西，但它仍然叫 C++。所以语言在原地发生变化，但语言集的变化越来越慢。是的，要添加什么，要问什么。
I mean, so TIOBE, I can't have it mentioned without just these piling on a little bit more. Listen, folks, it's hot garbage, you know, whatever their ranking is, like, Fortran and Cobol are like the two fastest growing languages. I think Fortran. Not this week? Not this week? All right, well, at some point there was like three arrows next to Fortran or Cobol or one of them. What are he talking about? Just because a couple banks were hiring a couple people. You're smoother.
我的意思是，所以 TIOBE，我不能不提它就稍微多说几句。听着，伙计们，这简直是垃圾，你知道，无论它们的排名如何，比如，Fortran 和 Cobol 是增长最快的两种语言。我想 Fortran。不是这周？不是这周？好吧，好吧，在某个时候，Fortran 或 Cobol 或其中之一旁边有三个箭头。他在说什么？仅仅因为几家银行雇了几个人。你更圆滑。
And then another thing is interesting is that stack overflow, it's on its last legs. Linguish, one of the sites that I linked to in plrank.com, it hasn't actually updated its latest. They usually do it on a quarterly basis, and it should have been updated in October, I know the guy, Tom Palmer, that does the site Context-free on YouTube, link in the show notes. Stack Overflow can't even run its queries anymore that he uses to generate the data. And so I think he just threw his hands up after a couple attempts. So anyways, you mentioned Stack Overflow and it not doing too well.
还有一件事很有趣，Stack Overflow，它已经快不行了。Linguish，我在 plrank.com 上链接的网站之一，它实际上没有更新它的最新数据。它们通常按季度进行，本应在 10 月份更新，我认识那个家伙，Tom Palmer，他在 YouTube 上做 Context-free，节目说明里有链接。Stack Overflow 甚至无法再运行他用来生成数据的查询了。所以我认为他在几次尝试后就放弃了。所以无论如何，你提到了 Stack Overflow，它表现不太好。
And it's probably a website that gives hints that may or may not be out of date when we now have perfect tools. Anyway, so yeah, languish, Stack Overflow, T-I-O-O-B-E. I totally agree. I mean, if you look at the rankings, you basically are to show in the facts. I mean, technically, according to some sites, Go, I think, is ranked 9th or 8th. So I think it's in the 10. It has actually hit the top 10.
而且它可能是一个网站，当现在我们有了完美的工具时，它给出的提示可能已经过时了。总之，是的，Linguish，Stack Overflow，TIOBE。我完全同意。我的意思是，如果你看排名，你基本上是在展示事实。我的意思是，从技术上讲，根据一些网站，Go，我想，排名第 9 或第 8。所以我认为它在前 10 名。它确实已经进入了前 10 名。
But it's funny because I usually every year in January, I make three programming language predictions. And I usually go one for three or two for three. But one of my predictions since I started doing it two or three years ago was that Rust, which I think is ranked like 13th or 12th. It's going to break into the top 10. and every year it doesn't, it just stays where it is. I can't remember if I predicted it last year. Anyway, so you always think, oh, there's a lot of momentum,
但这很有趣，因为我通常每年 1 月都会做三个编程语言预测。我通常三中一或三中二。但我从两三年前开始做这件事以来的预测之一是 Rust，我想它排名第 13 或第 12。它会进入前 10 名。每年它都没有，它只是停留在原来的位置。我不记得我去年是否预测过它。总之，你总是想，哦，有很多动力，
but you forget how many decades and millions, if not billions of lines of C++ code there are out there, and that's what you're competing against. And I guess I did see that in the Octover's survey this year by GitHub, that I don't know if it was TypeScript that switched with Python, but they had something in their theory, because they kind of pontificate as to why it's that for LLM's generating code,
但你忘记了外面有多少十年和数百万，如果不是数十亿行 C++ 代码，而这正是你所竞争的对象。我想我确实在 GitHub 今年的 Octoverse 调查中看到了这一点，我不知道是不是 TypeScript 和 Python 交换了位置，但他们在理论上有一些东西，因为他们推测为什么大语言模型生成代码时，
they use TypeScript way more often than JavaScript because it gives them another feedback mechanism to see it, you know, did I get the typing of this stuff, right? Anyway, so I guess the question is, if you had to, I guess maybe not predict the future, but how are these, you know, what people are reaching for? Is it going to be, you know, business as usual, and for the next five, ten years,
它们使用 TypeScript 的频率远高于 JavaScript，因为它给了它们另一个反馈机制来查看，你知道，我是否正确地输入了这些东西的类型？总之，我想问题是，如果你必须，我想也许不是预测未来，而是人们正在伸手去拿什么？是会，你知道，一切照旧，在未来五到十年内，
we're not going to see some big shift, or is there going to be more stuff like the TypeScript taking over JavaScript? Yeah, I think the TypeScript, that GitHub one is interesting. Don't forget the TypeScript is Microsoft. Hey, and so is GitHub. So, you know, it's kind of, there's an interesting thing there. That Anders-Halesburg interview, maybe I'll send Conner the link,
我们不会看到什么大的转变，还是会有更多像 TypeScript 取代 JavaScript 那样的东西？是的，我认为 TypeScript，GitHub 的那个很有趣。别忘了 TypeScript 是微软的。嘿，GitHub 也是。所以，你知道，那里有一件有趣的事情。那个 Anders Hejlsberg 的采访，也许我会把链接发给 Connor，
because that's an interesting one, because he's obviously talking about TypeScript there. But there is a case that in some of these cases, every single ranking is going to have some kind of spotlight bias on what it focuses on. The one that I talk about in the talk is I always say, well, when looking at GitHub, one has to be, I don't actually talk about the Microsoft buyers there because that's not actually representative of people that use it. But what I always point out is that some cultures and groups of people are freer at sharing code than others. So you're not going to find COBOL programmers
因为那很有趣，因为他显然在谈论 TypeScript。但有一种情况是，在其中一些案例中，每一个排名都会对它关注的内容有某种聚光灯偏见。我在演讲中谈到的那个，我总是说，嗯，在看 GitHub 时，一个人必须，我实际上没有谈论那里的微软偏见，因为那实际上并不代表使用它的人。但我总是指出，一些文化和群体比其他人更自由地分享代码。所以你不会找到 COBOL 程序员
committing to GitHub. But interesting, you'll find a lot of JavaScripters will quite happily put a single function up there, but C programmers are less likely to put small elements up there. There's no, it's not, C is not the kind of culture that is the, the NPM culture of JavaScript, the level, although there's open... They don't even have a package manager. Exactly. So the point there is there is a bias. So Rust gets very well represented as a language that has grown up in the open source
提交到 GitHub。但有趣的是，你会发现很多 JavaScript 程序员会很乐意把一个单一的函数放在那里，但 C 程序员不太可能把小的元素放在那里。没有，它不是，C 不是那种 JavaScript 的 NPM 文化，虽然有开源……他们甚至没有包管理器。完全正确。所以重点是存在偏见。所以 Rust 作为一种在开源空间中成长起来的语言得到了很好的代表，
space and has, you know, kind of end-to-end sort of support for packaging distribution to work. So there's always going to be that kind of nudge. And in particular, new software is going to be much more clear, new code is going to be much more clearly represented than old code locked away behind corporate doors and the closed source space. So we must always be sensitive to these. But the general sense I'm getting is that, yeah, there's movement in rust, there's movement and go, but always remembering that kind of the fact that whatever is at number 10 in whatever
并且有，你知道，某种端到端的打包分发支持。所以总会有那种推动力。特别是，新软件会更清晰，新代码会比锁在企业门后和闭源空间里的旧代码更清晰地呈现出来。所以我们必须始终对这些保持敏感。但我得到的一般感觉是，是的，Rust 有变动，Go 有变动，但始终要记住，无论排名第 10 的是什么，
ranking is probably an order of magnitude lower in adoption than whatever is at number one. So rust and go, yeah, having done variations of this talk for over a year, but also look back over some previous years, they are moving slowly up, and they're about to kind of break in on some rankings, not others. Rust has benefited hugely from, basically, you know, Linux has said, yeah, we'll allow some in. It's a case of you've got that acknowledged by that community. Microsoft have been saying for years that many of the issues, security and other bugs,
排名可能比第一名的采用率低一个数量级。所以 Rust 和 Go，是的，在做过一年多的这个演讲的变体后，但也回顾了过去几年，它们正在缓慢上升，并且它们即将进入某些排名，而不是其他排名。Rust 受益匪浅，基本上，你知道，Linux 已经说，是的，我们会允许一些进入。这是一个你被那个社区认可的情况。微软多年来一直说，许多问题，安全和其他错误，
it's just like, oh, when we do this in Rust, there's a lot better. So you've got somebody like Microsoft, you've got Microsoft and Linux effectively on the same side. which is like bizarre. Then you've got the US government going like, yeah, you want to be careful about certain memory safety language, which has inspired things happening in the C++ space, but more importantly, has again shot on the spotlight on other languages that have a slightly more rigorous approach
就像，哦，当我们用 Rust 做这个时，好多了。所以你有像微软这样的人，你有微软和 Linux 实际上站在同一边。这很奇怪。然后你有美国政府说，是的，你要小心某些内存安全语言，这激发了 C++ 空间中发生的事情，但更重要的是，它再次将聚光灯投向了其他对内存思考方式有稍微更严格方法的语言
to how they think about memory. So these are all nudges. That's going to change something, but there's nothing radical happening overnight. So my prediction for the next five years is those languages are probably going to be continuing there, They're kind of upward trend, but they are just outside the space where there is the killer Apple, the reason why everybody suddenly wants to do it.
所以这些都是推动力。这会改变一些事情，但不会一夜之间发生什么激进的事情。所以我对未来五年的预测是，这些语言可能会继续在那里，它们有一种上升趋势，但它们只是在那个杀手级应用之外，那个让每个人突然都想做它的原因。
And, you know, that's the thing. JavaScript, you know, kids are learning JavaScript because there's this kind of like unholy trinity of JavaScript, HTML and CSS. If you want to get into programming and do stuff at home, then that's one of the ways. You're out on the web with those three. Alternatively, you use Python because they teach it at school, but also it gets used for build systems. Oh, and also it gets used by data scientists. And in other words, it's very well represented in quite distinct communities.
而且，你知道，就是这样。JavaScript，你知道，孩子们正在学习 JavaScript，因为有这种 JavaScript、HTML 和 CSS 的邪恶三位一体。如果你想进入编程并在家里做一些事情，那么这是途径之一。你和那三个在网上。或者，你使用 Python，因为他们在学校教它，而且它也被用于构建系统。哦，它也被数据科学家使用。换句话说，它在相当不同的社区中表现得非常好。
There's not one reason Python is there. There's actually half a dozen to a dozen. And that's going to be a hard one to dislodge, even without the question of incumbent code. It's just represented so well. So you kind of need a language to have either a really strong, specific appeal that suddenly becomes hugely popular. Objective C and the Apple ecosystem, or from Next originally, but that took a language that was dead. I saw Objective C in the early 90s, and it was already on its way out.
Python 在那里不仅仅有一个原因。实际上有六到十二个。即使没有现任代码的问题，这也将是一个很难被取代的语言。它表现得太好了。所以你需要一种语言要么有非常强烈的、特定的吸引力，突然变得非常流行。Objective C 和苹果生态系统，或者最初来自 Next，但这采用了一种已经死掉的语言。我在 90 年代初看到了 Objective C，它已经在走下坡路了。
That was Stepstone Corporation, and it was only because of Next Step and then, well, no, not even Next Step. It was Apple buying Next Step and saying, hey, we're going to use this for Mac OS and then iOS. That made that. And now it is dropping like a stone because of Swift. It's not dead yet, but it is dropping like a stone
那是 Stepstone Corporation，仅仅是因为 Next Step，然后，嗯，不，甚至不是 Next Step。是苹果收购了 Next Step 并说，嘿，我们要把这个用于 Mac OS，然后是 iOS。这造就了它。现在它因为 Swift 而像石头一样坠落。它还没死，但它正在像石头一样坠落
because it relied on one source of support. You need a language that has broad support. And that's the key. I think that's going to be the key to any languages uptake, a killer app, broad support, representation across a lot of disparate spaces. And that's going to drive these things. Everything else is just going to move up and down, a little nudge at a time, various reasons.
因为它依赖于单一的支持来源。你需要一种拥有广泛支持的语言。这就是关键。我认为这将是任何语言被采用的关键，一个杀手级应用，广泛的支持，在许多不同空间中的代表性。这将推动这些事情。其他一切都只会上下波动，一次一点点推动，各种原因。
Systems programmers kind of say, I've got enough performance. Maybe I'll go for an interpreted language or a VM-based language. It's okay. Stuff is fast enough. maybe I didn't need to worry about the speed I thought I needed a decade ago. So, you know, I think that's one of the things. I think if you dropped into a time machine and went back to 2005 and said,
系统程序员会说，我有足够的性能。也许我会选择一种解释型语言或基于虚拟机的语言。没关系。东西足够快了。也许我不需要担心我十年前认为我需要的速度。所以，你知道，我认为这是其中之一。我认为如果你掉进时间机器回到 2005 年，说，
guess what we used to do a lot of, you know, a lot of our work. Oh, what do you do? Number crunching. Oh, okay. What are you using? You're using C++? Oh, we're using Python. They would just laugh in your face.
猜猜我们过去做了很多什么，你知道，我们很多工作。哦，你做什么？数字运算。哦，好吧。你在用什么？你在用 C++？哦，我们在用 Python。他们会直接嘲笑你。
We've got to a point where the landscape has changed in terms of performance and library relationships. You know, so I think that I'm not going to make any specifically wrong predictions, but these are all kind of vague suggestions. Obviously, my role is futurologists, you know, I've got to say something's safe. But, yeah, it's going to move in gentle ways. All right, well, I just heard the applause of the Sam Aaron closing keynote. I don't actually know if it's the last talk of day one. So we're going to be flooded by a couple people.
我们已经到了一个景观在性能和库关系方面发生变化的程度。你知道，所以我认为我不会做出任何特别错误的预测，但这些都是某种模糊的建议。显然，我的角色是未来学家，你知道，我必须说一些安全的话。但是，是的，它会以温和的方式移动。好吧，好吧，我刚刚听到了 Sam Aaron 闭幕主题演讲的掌声。我实际上不知道这是否是第一天的最后一场演讲。所以我们会被几个人淹没。
But last two questions that we can do rapid fire. if you would point people at one talk, or if two, if you have to, from the Yale conference, that were your personal favorites that you saw? And then two, it's the end of 2025, so maybe 2026 hasn't happened your scheduling of conferences. But if you're going to be anywhere, you know, let the people know where they can find you. And we've got like 60 seconds before the noise here is going to quadruple in a decibel level. Okay, Sam Aaron's talk, absolutely brilliant. Sam Aaron created Sonic Pie.
但最后两个问题我们可以快速回答。如果你要向人们推荐一场演讲，或者如果必须的话，两场，来自 Yao 大会的，是你个人最喜欢的？然后二，现在是 2025 年底，所以也许 2026 年还没有安排你的会议。但如果你要去任何地方，你知道，让人们知道在哪里可以找到你。我们还有大约 60 秒，这里的噪音分贝水平就会翻四倍。好的，Sam Aaron 的演讲，绝对精彩。Sam Aaron 创造了 Sonic Pie。
There's some really good stuff there. Captain John Will's talk on basically kind of hacking AI is really also worth catching. And likewise, Michael Feathers talk on conceptualization. I would recommend these. And where, do you have a conference schedule for 2026 yet? Oh, good question. Yeah, there's a lot of maybes. I'm hoping to be at Kraft in Budapest.
那里有一些非常好的东西。Captain John Will 关于基本上某种黑客人工智能的演讲也确实值得一看。同样，Michael Feathers 关于概念化的演讲。我会推荐这些。还有哪里，你 2026 年有会议日程了吗？哦，好问题。是的，有很多可能。我希望去布达佩斯的 Kraft。
I'm expecting to be I'm doing Voxed at CERN and then into Chino and I think the rest are just guesswork and hope thanks so much Kevlin
我预计会去，我正在 CERN 做 Voxed，然后去 Chino，我想剩下的只是猜测和希望，非常感谢 Kevlin
we'll do this again sometime we might take this on to the end of episode 265 we were just chatting with Kevlin I'm okay I've just been offered a vegetarian something something we're talking to Damien
我们以后再做一次。我们可能会把这个带到第 265 期的结尾。我们刚才在和 Kevlin 聊天，我很好，我刚刚被提供了一种素食什么的，我们正在和 Damien 谈话
technical director and Damien just stepped into this role six months ago, took over for, I believe, Stefan, am I pronouncing that correctly? So I, Stefan reached out to me, I think, a year ago. Asking if I wanted to speak at the 2024 edition, I was already had commitments, but then I said I'd love to next year, and then you swooped in halfway through. So this is your first, I mean, not your first Yao, but first Yao is technical director. You've been, I think you said you've been coming since basically the Genesis.
技术总监，Damien 六个月前刚担任这个角色，接替了，我相信是 Stefan，我发音正确吗？所以我，Stefan 大概一年前联系了我。问我是否想在 2024 年的版本中发言，我已经有承诺了，但我说我明年很乐意，然后你中途插进来了。所以这是你的第一次，我的意思是，不是你的第一次 Yao，但第一次作为技术总监的 Yao。我想你说过你基本上从创世纪就开始来了。
15 years. 15 years. So tell us, how has this? this edition, being technical director, gone. What were your favorite talks? What were the highlights? And what can people expect? Because I imagine you're going to be organizing this edition next year.
15 年。15 年。所以告诉我们，作为技术总监，这次怎么样？你最喜欢的演讲是什么？亮点是什么？人们可以期待什么？因为我想你明年会组织这个版本。
So, yeah, just tell us all the things and what people can expect in 2026. It's too early to tell for 2026. We need to debrief this one. Look, I've really enjoyed this year. It's been a really nice program, a good mix of speakers. I think the last few years, everyone is very scared of AI. I think what we're seeing with this edition is, we still have jobs. There's still a future. We're still needed. Our insight is still needed. The robots aren't going to replace us just yet. And the fundamentals still matter.
所以，是的，告诉我们所有的事情，人们在 2026 年可以期待什么。现在说 2026 年还为时过早。我们需要总结一下这次。看，我真的很喜欢今年。这是一个非常好的项目，演讲者组合很好。我认为过去几年，每个人都非常害怕人工智能。我认为我们在这个版本中看到的是，我们仍然有工作。未来依然存在。我们仍然被需要。我们的洞察力仍然被需要。机器人暂时还不会取代我们。基础知识仍然很重要。
I mean, we saw in a couple different talks, the same or the same slide, not exactly, but they would say that, you know, in this age of, you know, the age of AI and LLMs, it's actually more developers that are needed, not less. And this idea that that junior developers are no longer is the complete opposite. Is that the case? It's like, we're in a world now where, it's the on-ramped to coding has gotten even easier. How is that going to lead to less jobs? So I think that's a fantastic sentiment. I mean, you've seen a number of the talks. I mean, it's hard to, it's like picking favorites with kids and stuff. But if you had to recommend one or two or three, what are the first ones you would point people at once,
我的意思是，我们在几场不同的演讲中看到了同样或类似的幻灯片，不完全一样，但他们会说，你知道，在这个时代，你知道，人工智能和大型语言模型的时代，实际上需要更多的开发者，而不是更少。这种初级开发者不再需要的想法完全相反。是这样吗？就像，我们现在处于一个世界，编码的入门门槛变得更容易了。这怎么会导致工作减少？所以我认为这是一个非常棒的观点。我的意思是，你看了很多演讲。我的意思是，这很难，就像在孩子中挑选最喜欢的等等。但如果你必须推荐一两个或三个，你会首先向人们指出哪些，
because these are going to be up on YouTube. Which ones would you point people at? That's a tough thing to ask me. I can't answer that one. They're all good. Look, I think the opening keynote, I think Kent's talk gives us. a lot of hope for people. And again, it is that we're still needed. The junior thing was
因为这些会上传到 YouTube。你会向人们指出哪些？这是一个很难问我的问题。我回答不了那个。它们都很好。看，我认为开幕主题演讲，我认为 Kent 的演讲给了我们。很多希望。再说一次，我们仍然被需要。初级的事情是
especially good. A lot of people have looked at AI as a replacement for juniors because it's more productive. And Kent's insight that we don't get juniors for their productivity. We're essentially taking an option on their future productivity. And so get the juniors, teach them, use the AI, use the AI to teach them, and then, you know, it's an investment into the future. So I think that was a really nice hopeful message for everybody. Completely agree. And we've also had a, conversation earlier in the week that was about how in this age of remote work, because I work entirely remote, that these conferences honestly have, for me, become even more important because
特别好。很多人把人工智能看作是初级开发者的替代品，因为它更有效率。Kent 的洞察力是，我们雇佣初级开发者不是为了他们的生产力。我们本质上是在对他们未来的生产力进行期权投资。所以雇佣初级开发者，教他们，使用人工智能，使用人工智能来教他们，然后，你知道，这是对未来的投资。所以我认为这对每个人来说都是一个非常好的充满希望的信息。完全同意。而且我们本周早些时候也进行了一次对话，关于在这个远程工作的时代，因为我完全远程工作，这些会议对我来说老实说变得更加重要，因为
the socializing that I, it's not socializing is the wrong word, but it's a form of socializing and networking. I miss out on that entirely as I work remote. And you can get basically a concentrated version of that, not just from employees at your company, but across the industry and hear different stories. Anyways, and you were saying basically that we have to do a better job. I mean, you're a conference technical director of putting that message out there that, you know, this has really even become a more valuable thing, which, anyways, I'll let you add to that. Yeah, look, absolutely. In the last few years, we've seen, like, a lot of the content that people
我错过的社交，社交这个词用错了，但它是一种社交和网络形式。我完全错过了，因为我远程工作。你可以基本上得到一个浓缩的版本，不仅来自你公司的员工，而且来自整个行业，并听到不同的故事。总之，你说过我们必须做得更好。我的意思是，你是一位会议技术总监，传达那个信息，你知道，这确实变得更有价值了，无论如何，我会让你补充这一点。是的，看，绝对。在过去几年里，我们看到，像人们来参加会议的很多内容，
come to conferences for, you can find that online. There's so much of it on YouTube. What you cannot get on YouTube is what we're doing right now, the hallway track, standing around, meeting people, discussing the talks, you know, exchanging of ideas, and we've exchanged a lot of ideas this week. There's been some robust exchanging of ideas. This hallway track cannot be replaced, and yes, it is even more important. Like you, I've worked remote for many, many years. I've long said, yeah, it was my Christmas party.
你可以在网上找到。YouTube 上有很多。你在 YouTube 上得不到的是我们现在正在做的，走廊轨道，站在那里，结识人们，讨论演讲，你知道，交流想法，我们这周交流了很多想法。这周有很多强有力的想法交流。这个走廊轨道是无法替代的，是的，它甚至更重要。像你一样，我远程工作了很多很多年。我早就说，是的，这是我的圣诞派对。
This is where I come to hang out with my people. So, yeah, I think we need to get that message out there that conferences are more important than ever because you don't get this online. Yeah, I think it was, I hadn't. attended my first conference this year was in September and you don't realize what you have until you're reminded and then when I went I was like oh my God like I've forgotten what it's like to give a talk in person where people immediately come up afterwards and they tell you like you can give an online talk you maybe get one or two questions in the chat and then it's just poof the screen
这是我来和我的伙伴们闲逛的地方。所以，是的，我认为我们需要传达那个信息，会议比以往任何时候都更重要，因为你在网上得不到这个。是的，我想是这样，我今年九月才参加了我的第一次会议，直到被提醒，你才意识到你拥有什么，然后当我去了，我就像，天哪，我忘记了亲自演讲是什么感觉，人们会立即走过来，他们告诉你，你可以做一个在线演讲，你可能在聊天中得到一两个问题，然后它就砰地一声，屏幕
goes black and you're kind of there's like a little bit of an emptiness inside it's exhausting it's exhausting as well I've done remote training just with to 30 people with their screens off and it's no fun for anybody um so yeah something i will say is most years at yow when i've come i've walked away just super inspired like i want to go on a bill i want to go away and build something and i've felt that again this this time around with yow even though i'm working here and you know i'm running around doing a bunch of things i sit and know what you're talking i'm like i need to build i need to build i'm going to pick up that project that i'd abandon so um yeah i i always get very inspired at Yao and come away wanting to do stuff. So definitely feeling that.
屏幕变黑了，你会有种空虚感，这也很累人。我曾经给30个人做过远程培训，他们都关着屏幕，这对谁来说都没意思。嗯，所以我想说的是，大多数时候我来参加YOW大会，离开时都感到非常受鼓舞，我想去构建一些东西。这次参加YOW，尽管我在这里工作，忙得团团转，但我听着你们的谈话，心里还是想着我需要去构建，我需要去构建，我要捡起那个我放弃的项目。所以，是的，我在YOW总是感到非常受鼓舞，离开时总想做点什么。我确实有这种感觉。
100%. I feel the exact same way. Anyways, thank you for talking. Hopefully this is Audible listeners. They close the doors and the decibel value. So if it's not good, we'll get you, we'll just have to come back next year and do another interview. But thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you for coming. It's been great. It's been awesome. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is
百分之百。我也有同感。总之，谢谢你的交谈。希望听众能听得清楚。他们关上了门，隔绝了噪音。如果效果不好，我们明年再来做一次采访。但非常感谢你。谢谢。谢谢你的到来。这太棒了，太精彩了。请务必查看节目说明，可以在你的播客应用中查看，或者访问ADSP thepodcast.com获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。那不是口号。我们的口号是
chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
混乱中点缀着信息。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。